she's just gone off war rebellion and
revolution for more than a decade I've
been outside Britain reporting on some
of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and I want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
12 years
[Music]
first and foremost I'm I I'm very
passionate Welshman but at the same time
I'm extremely passionate be British as
well hey good it's just 24 Jacob already
knows what a risky business farming is
it's extremely tough for me again Smith
extremely tough steady goes I'm a fifth
generation in the family since 1926 this
five of us is my grandfather as well
live here and there's no set how are you
don't know what time you're coming in
and like if I just do I'll just do two
or three the how old did you say you
should be I'm two weeks now on Saturday
spending time with Jacob I'm learning
more about farming it's quite a nice
feeling isn't it feed in the car flakes
quite satisfying isn't it finding out
how different the regions are and how
Europe is changing their outlook do you
feel European I
vivix honest no I don't feel European I
feel more I feel more either linked with
the Commonwealth countries than I to any
of the European countries to be
perfectly honest and this is all your
own your own produce Emma yes yeah it's
all homegrown beef yeah my traditional
Welsh black beef three generations of
the family live work and eat together on
the farm and they've seen the industry
alter what would you say is the biggest
change helpfulness I think everyone used
to seem to be it helped one another but
today there's a tendency of what's in it
for me so this happens every day we have
lunch every day
staff lunch there's history here an 85
year old david has lived a lot of it
there are many families here like Ward
and members and family who fought to
save it those Europeans
twice in their lifetime some of them
they fought in the First World War and
he fought it after it's again and they
trying to dictate to us if you were in
passionate about then you didn't have a
love affair you wouldn't be doing it
because unfortunately the rewards in the
financial sense aren't there for farmers
at the moment how are things change for
you over the past twelve years in that
respect all right it definitely isn't
the returns that they were then twelve
years ago things things have become
tight there the current recent recently
told me that if it was any other
business the best thing we could do
would be to close a business down and
liquidate our assets if you're in this
family
farming's a lifelong commitment retiring
not for some time I'm I'm not going to
retire I'm tired now but I'm not
retiring no is there anything more
picturesque than sheep grazing the
fields in the South Wales Valleys
there's nothing more picture asking this
Welsh lamb is such a premium product